alte mutter warum beschäftigt sich ein
schriftsteller und philosoph so intensiv
mit religion origin ist
ich finde religionen sind die
wichtigsten ideen systeme die die welt
je hervorgebracht hat
seit jahrtausenden kontrollieren
religionen die menschen vor moment
unserer geburt an ist zu unserer
todesstunde sagen sie uns was wir zu tun
haben
als heutiger intellektueller muss man
die geschichte und die bedeutung der
religionen verstehen sonst habe man im
dunkeln
auch wer nicht glaubt muss anerkennen
dass vieles was uns heute ausmacht von
den religionen geschaffen oder von ihnen
beeinflusst wurde
sie haben das buch geschrieben religion
für atheisten es ist vor kurzem auf
deutsch erschienen
am anfang dieses buches beschreiben sie
wie es zu diesem projekt kam sie sagen
sie waren sehr streng katholisch erzogen
worden man hat ihnen beigebracht
religion sei etwas lächerliches und sie
merken aber mit der zeit dass es immer
mehr dinge gab religiöse dinge die ihnen
eigentlich gefielen das hat sie
irritiert und ruhm ist in bar ist ja ich
schämte mich fast ein wenig als ich mit
der zeit merkte dass mir gewisse
religiöse aspekte gefiel die
übernatürlichen dogmen habe ich nie
akzeptiert ich glaubte nie dass jesus in
den himmel aufgefahren ist oder moses
das rote meer geteilt hatte das fand ich
immer seltsam aber ich entdeckte
religiöse dinge die mir gefiel die
atmosphäre alte kirchen das gemeinsame
singen in der weihnachtszeit musik wie
bachs h-moll-messe philosophische texte
von kirchenvätern wie dem heiligen
augustinus solche dinge fand ich schön
und gut aber ich wusste nicht wie ich
das einordnen sollte durfte ich als
atheist bachs musik mögen oder in einer
alten kirche fast zu tränen gerührt sein
das normal lange fühlte ich mich seltsam
ich war hin und hergerissen
schließlich mir schließlich sagte die
religionen stammen nicht von gott
sondern wurden von menschen erfunden
anders gesagt sie sind werke der kultur
und wurden wie die literatur und die
philosophie von uns geschaffen
also kann auch jemand der nicht glaubt
dass sich für religionen interessieren
sie sind für alle da nicht nur für jene
die daran glauben diese überlegung gab
mir die freiheit religionen zu studieren
in ihrem elternhaus
sie sind in zürich aufgewachsen und dann
nach england gezogen
ihre eltern waren ursprünglich waren sie
nie praktiziert
wir haben den glauben nie praktiziert
meine eltern gehörte jener generation an
die den zweiten weltkrieg miterlebt und
deren familien darunter gelitten hatten
sie machten die religion dafür
mitverantwortlich deshalb strebt sie
eine zukunft ohne religion
sie glaubten an die technologien die
wissenschaft an die wirtschaft und an
die zukunft die zukunft erfüllte sie mit
enthusiasmus
ich erinnere mich noch als ich klein war
kann man manchmal leute zu uns heute
meine eltern sagten sie sind so
sympathisch wie schade dass sie gläubig
sind an eine religion zu glauben war für
sie als würde man an fehlen glauben
eigentlich sagen sie es als zeichen der
dummheit
mit dieser botschaft bin ich
aufgewachsen und erst viel später habe
ich mich gefragt ist das wirklich wahr
kann das sein
ist das alles tun und es dauerte lange
bis ich mir die freiheit nahm zu sagen
eigentlich finde ich dieses religiöse
buch oder diese kirche großartig
trotzdem fühlte ich mich ein wenig
schuldig wenn ich an meine eltern dachte
mein vater ist tot aber ich glaube er
hätte mich für dieses buch sehr
bemitleidet er hätte gedacht ich sei
schwachsinnig geworden
er wäre wohl etwas traurig gewesen
sie wissen ja sehr gut bescheid über die
jüdische religion das merkt man auch im
buch haben sie das trotzdem von ihren
eltern mitgekriegt oder haben sie das
alles gelesen
mehr war als kind sehr wohl bewusst dass
ich jude war
aber ich wusste nicht was das bedeutet
die spürte es war etwas besonderes und
andersartiges aber ich wusste nur das
was ich aus woody allens filmen kannte
die jüdischen traditionen sagten mir
nichts dieses buch war eine chance für
mich den religiösen hintergrund kennen
zu lernen dem ich eine stange den ich
aber nie richtig verstanden hatte ich
habe drei religionen ausgewählt zuerst
das judentum dann das christentum und
zwar vor allem den katholizismus
denn für juden sind die katholiken
faszinierend sozusagen die feinde die
anderen
das war interessant außerdem analysierte
ich den buddhismus auch darüber wusste
ich nicht viel aber ich liebe diesen
kunst ich war in japan und mir gefielen
die dortigen tempel
deshalb wollte ich mehr darüber erfahren
aber im buch vergleiche ich die
religionen mit der modernen ungläubigen
welt es ist kein vergleich zwischen den
verschiedenen religionen sondern
zwischen dem religiösen und dem
säkularen leben noch anschauen aber erst
die frage gab es denn auch phasen wo sie
an ihrem abriss muss zwei füttern obwohl
sie vielleicht die idee es könnte einen
gott deutschland leben nach dem tod
geben nicht mehr ganz so absurd ehrlich
gesagt nein meine religiösen freunde
sagen immer spürst du nicht manchmal
dass es da etwas gibt und ich sage nein
kürzlich war ich mit einem freund im
garten wir betrachteten die sterne und
er fragte ist das nicht schön das ist
doch einer dieser momente in denen man
sich klein fühlt angesichts von etwas
größerem ist das nicht beruhigend für
die seele
worauf ich entgegnete ich verstehe die
beruhigende wirkung auf die seele aber
warum muss das religiös sei da meinte er
aber du spürst doch sicher dass es da
oben etwas gibt
ich antwortete nein das spüre ich nicht
ehrlich gesagt habe ich keine religiösen
gefühle manchmal werde ich von leuten
aufgefordert öffne jesus dein herz
da kann ich nur sagen mein herz ist weit
offen aber es kommt niemand
ich habe nichts gegen solche
überzeugungs versuche aber ich denke
religiöse gefühle sind oft unbewusst und
wir verstehen nicht warum wir sie haben
ich finde es schrecklich dass leute sich
gegenseitig bekehren wollen der gläubige
sagt ihr seid zehn gründe warum du
glauben sollst und der atheist entgegnet
hier sind zehn gründe die dagegen
sprechen aber sie überzeugen einander
nicht sondern machen nur ein land habe
in meinem buch sage ich deshalb leicht
zu begehen klipp und klar für mich
existiert gott nicht punkt ich vergeude
nicht 300 seiten um das zu beweisen denn
wirklich interessant ist für mich was
wir tun nachdem wir zum schluss gekommen
sind dass es gott nicht gibt
ob er existiert oder nicht darüber
können wir die nächsten 1000 jahre
diskutiert aber für einen atheisten ist
es wichtig sich zu fragen wie lebe ich
in einer welt die all das was uns die
religion gegeben hat nicht mehr bietet
das hat mich interessiert und fasziniert
werden sie dann anders legen wir uns
jetzt an ein leben nach dem tod glauben
wurden bestimmt ich würde mich viel
geborgener führen haben ich glaube nicht
an gott aber manchmal vermisse ich ihn
heute beliefert dann verstehe ich dass
es momente gibt in denen gott wichtig
oder nötig wäre
trotzdem glaube ich nicht an ihn obwohl
ich vor allem in krisen wenn ich mich
einsam fühle oder verzweifelt bin
manchmal denke es wäre wirklich schön
wenn ein engel oder gott mir bei stünde
aber ich lebe ein leben ohne gott es ist
ein einsames leben aber ich verstehe
genug von religion um zu wissen wann
religiöse menschen gott braucht man was
sie tun wenn sie dieses bedürfnis haben
und das interessiert
also was ist es denn was der säkularen
fällt so sehr fehlt dass er es bei den
religionen suchen wo zu finden so viele
dinge laufen sehr gut in der säkularen
welt vor allem in einem land wie der
schweiz das rechtssystem ist gut die
wirtschaft läuft befriedigend und die
bildung ist in vieler hinsicht in
ordnung aber wie steht es um das innere
leben der menschen dass man seele nennen
könnte ich kann den begriff seele
verwenden ohne an eine übernatürliche
dimension zu glauben es ist der
kostbarste persönlichste bereiche holz
und wer bereitet uns oft probleme wir
fühlen uns allein haben angst wir machen
uns sorgen und führen uns isoliert keine
gemeinschaft zu gehören
wir leben in einer einsamen welt andere
menschen stören uns zwar nicht aber es
ist auch schwierig sie zu erreichen und
sich gegenseitig zu unterstützen haben
wir leben in einer welt die bildung sehr
ernst nimmt man sagt uns wie man
steuerberater schreiner oder pilot wird
aber kaum jemand außerhalb von
glaubensgemeinschaften bringt uns bei
wie wir leben und von welchen
moralischen grundsätzen wir uns leiten
lassen sollen oder wie der trost und
sinn finden angesichts von
schicksalsschlägen wie dem tod
da sind wir uns selbst überlassen
früher suchte man einen priester auf der
von der geburt bis zum tod für einen
dabei wäre ein problem hatte ging zum
priester es gab schlechte aber auch gute
priester denen man sich anvertrauen
konnte in der modernen welt sehe ich
großen technologischen und
wirtschaftlichen erfolg aber massive
schwierigkeiten in psychologischen und
gefühlsmäßigen belange unter anderem
weil die säkulare welt einige lektionen
der religion vergessen hat die hatten es
so eilig alles religiöse loszuwerden und
aus unserem leben zu verbannen
dass wir aufgehört haben die vielen
positiven dinge zu sehen die religionen
zu bieten haben und die sogar für leute
die nicht glauben interessant und
nützlich sein können hüther und belieben
also heißt dass man hat in unserer
gesellschaft das kind mit dem bade
ausgeschüttet
allerdings haben wir haben das kind mit
dem bad ausgeschüttet
in so vielen bereichen zb in der
erziehung hatten
ihr angst wurde kirchlichen propaganda
der sogenannten gehirnwäsche der
religionen
wir haben also alles religiöse aus
erziehung und bildung verband ein
schwerpunkt der religiösen erziehung war
uns beizubringen gut zu sein ist das
klingt sehr seltsam was heißt gut sein
wenn ich zu ihnen sagen würde diese
woche werde ich trainiere gut zu sein
ich mache studien in gut sein
dann käme das wahrscheinlich seltsam
würde ich sagen ich tue etwas für meine
gesundheit und gehen im fitnessclub wäre
das normal
auch mehr geld verdienen zu wollen ist
normal sage ich hingegen ich will ein
guter mensch werden ist dass er selbst
das zeigt folgendes wir haben vergessen
dass es legitim ist gut sein zu wollen
und genau das steht im fokus aller
großen religionen ein bis zweimal am tag
einmal pro woche oder monat ermahnen sie
uns denkt daran gut zu sein versuche
freundlich und verständnisvoll zu sein
und gut zu sein ist keine intellektuelle
angelegenheit wir werden vielmehr immer
wieder durch etwas das wir sehen oder
hören daran erinnert dass wir gut sein
wollen
denn die meisten von uns wollen gut sein
heutzutage ist man vielleicht versucht
zu sagen niemand weiß das und ist wie
kann da jemand anderen beibringen was
gut ist als wäre das etwas mysteriöses
was natürlich nicht stimmt
sie und ich können verhaltensweisen
aufzählen die wir beide gut finden
am ende meines buchs habe ich denn auch
ein paar säkulare tugenden wie ich sie
nenne aufgelistet die atheisten und
gläubige gutheißen könnten zb empathie
gelassenheit verständnis großzügigkeit
humor
diese dinge brauchen wir alle wenn die
welt schlecht ist dann oft weil wir
diese kleinen alltäglichen tugenden
vergessen haben
in einer säkularen welt haben wir
gesetze
man darf geschwindigkeitslimit nicht
überschreiten muss steuern bezahlen und
so weiter doch gesetze machen uns nicht
liebenswürdig sie verhindern vielleicht
nord oder diebstahl
ermutigen uns aber nicht zu kleinen
akten von großzügigkeit sympathie oder
liebenswürdigkeit
doch mir scheint damit eine gesellschaft
gut funktioniert müssen wir an solche
dinge erinnert werden durch kleine
denkanstöße die wenigsten von uns waren
am morgen mit dem vorsatz auf heute
werde ich böse sein und niemand soll
mich daran hindern
natürlich will ich gut sein aber dann
wäre ich gestresst komme zu spät wenn
verunsichert oder andere treibt mich zur
weißglut und es gelingt mir nicht nett
zu sein
es ist deshalb hilfreich wenn uns jemand
sagt einen moment denkt daran das ist
nicht so wichtig versuche dich zu
beruhigen kleine moralische botschaften
würden oft den gang der dinge ändern
das wissen die religionen fünf oder zehn
mal am tag mahnen sie uns einen moment
des die bessere verhaltensweisen in der
weihnachtszeit tun wir das ganz
natürlich zwei wochen vor und vielleicht
eine woche nach weihnachten sind alle
ziemlich nett zueinander
die leute denken ich darf nicht eklig
sein das tut man nicht an weihnachten
man entlässt keine angestellten
man fragt andere wie es ihnen geht denn
es herrscht so etwas wie eine moralische
atmosphäre an weihnachten wird man davon
angesteckt ob man glaubt oder nicht denn
sie ist sehr dominant
während des restlichen jahres gibt es
diese moralische atmosphäre nicht
deshalb können kleine anwandlungen von
boshaftigkeit oder unfreundlichkeit viel
eher überhand nehmen
[Musik]
ja man kann alles mögliche tun also erst
einmal und das haben die religionen
gemerkt vor allem der katholizismus
wer wir sind und wie wir uns fühlen hat
viel mit dem raum zu tun in dem wir uns
deshalb bauen religionen kirchen weil
sie wissen dass man nicht überall gleich
ist in einem supermarkt ist man eine
andere person als im büro mit ihnen in
eine
eine kirche gehe sind sie ruhiger und
empfänglicher für gewisse dinge
sie sind mehr in frieden mit sich selbst
der raum der sich positiv auf die psyche
aus
normalerweise werden räume nicht nach
psychologischen grundsätzen gebaut
manchmal heißt es hier darf man keinen
supermarkt bauen oder hier darf ein
hochhaus nur zehn etagen haben aber wir
glauben nicht ernsthaft daran dass wir
von den botschaften um uns herum
beeinflusst werden das impact of dance
gehen sie in zürich eine straße lang
werden riesige plakate für diese uhr
oder jenes schokoladen getränk oder
ferien in irgendeinem land
wir achten darauf wir nehmen diese
botschaften auf wird werbung
funktioniert vieles was religionen tun
ist mit werbung vergleichbaren aber es
ist werbung für unser tiefstes wesen für
unsere seele mein rat ist dass wir viel
mehr darauf achten wie das fernsehen die
zeitungen und die werbung botschaften
verbreiten sie schaffen eine bestimmte
atmosphäre dieses feld haben wir dem
freien markt dem kapitalismus überlassen
heutzutage über malen wir ganze drums
mit werbebotschaften
was geschieht mit uns wenn ihr auf einem
tram die werbebotschaft einer bank lesen
im grunde bedeutet es dass die
gemeinschaft weniger wichtig ist als die
bank eine gefährliche botschaft aber das
ist weiß nicht wirklich bewusst die
religionen hingegen nehmen das sehr
ernst sie denken oft darüber nach wie
die velos uns wirkt denn sie sorgen sich
um unser innerstes wesen
es gibt in zürich vielleicht ich weiß
nicht vielleicht sogar der ganzen
schweiz plakate dastehen steht einfach
ein bibelspruch traf da gibt jemand
wahnsinnig viel geld dafür aus weil das
ist teuer an den sehr guten orten diese
plakate abzuhängen
aber ich glaube die meisten leute finden
das nur lächerlich ich weiß nicht wie
diese plakate gestaltet sind sie sagen
es sind botschaften aus der bibel
viele empfinden das wohl als religiöse
propaganda aber es ist erstaunlich
leiter einer werbeagentur larsen dieses
buch kamen zu mir und sagten wir wollen
eine werbekampagne mit tugenden mit dem
konzept des gutscheins machen
sie kreierten wunderbare plakate hängten
sie in ganz london auf und hatten großen
erfolg damit
unter anderem weil sie wunderschön und
clever gestaltet waren solche plakate
müssen sehr gut gemacht sascha warum hat
die kirche aufträge amana wie tizian
rembrandt und giovanni bellini vergeben
weil sie wusste dass religiöse
botschaften nur ankommen wenn man sie in
phantastische kunst packt ich habe die
plakate nicht gesehen die sie erwähnt
haben aber ich fürchte die religiösen
botschaften sind von einem eher
mittelmäßigen künstler gestaltet worden
service ist das muss uns bewusst sein
kunst ist kein luxus sondern das medium
durch das jede botschaft vermittelt
werden muss
haben sie also etwas wichtiges zu sagen
achten sie darauf dass es gut gestaltet
ist beauftragen sie künstler damit die
botschaft ankommt
diese buskampagne der artisten
werbekampagne eigentlich weiß nicht mehr
genau wie das laufen glaubt es gibt
keinen gott genieße das leben irgendwie
einige aggressive atheisten um den
evolutionsbiologen richard dawkins
begannen dinge zu verbreiten wie kinder
dürfen nicht mit religionen in berührung
kommen alles religiöse muss vom
öffentlichen grund verschwinden kirchen
müssen geschlossen werden und so weiter
das finde ich zu aggressiv ich vertrete
einen anderen atheismus
ich glaube nicht an gott aber um in der
modernen welt ein gutes leben führen zu
können muss man die religionen verstehen
man kann nicht sagen ich bin gläubig
also schaffen wir die religionen ab
religion ist ein teil von uns und gibt
uns viele hinweise darauf was wir
brauchen um einfach gesagt wie glücklich
zu sein
aber eigentlich ist dann der titel ihres
buches religionen für atheisten doch
falsch weil was sie wollen ja nicht
ehrlich und sie wollen auch nicht
religiös von einer rückbindung an etwas
göttliches
ich fordere nicht dass atheisten
religiös werden sollen
das suggerierte titel nicht ich will
filme aufzeigen wie atheisten die
religion sehen können
es ist mein buch ist ein führer der
dinge auflistet die atheisten von
gewissen religiösen aspekten lernen
können
vom aspekt zu verletzen
wir werden diese aspekte jetzt anschauen
und zwar beginnen wir mit architektur
wir haben dafür einen kleinen
filmbeitrag vorbereitet und zwar aus der
sendung kulturplatz vom 17
april
was ist es bloß dass unser innerstes
berührt in solchen räumen
die macht einer kathedrale spüren nicht
nur gläubige auch atheisten brauchen
tempel meint alle an die brutto einen
hohepriester der baukunst peter zu tor
hat er sich dafür ins boot geholt er
baut einen rückzugsort eine einsiedelei
für atheisten an einem entlegenen ort in
süddeutschland wo man sich versenken
kann wie im kloster ganz ohne gott
jannis diesem projekt eines secure
retreat seines besinnungslos für
atheisten gibt es das projekt ein tempel
für atheisten sie wollen diesen baum im
bankenviertel in london glaube ich wie
weit ist dieses projekt
ich setze nicht dass tempel projekt um
sondern genau dieses projekt mit peter
zumthors berufe er baut für eine
organisation an der ich beteiligt bin
einen säkularen rückzugsort ein gebäude
das in klöster erinnert obwohl es kein
kloster ist berücksichtigt es ein paar
wichtige klösterliche strategien so
schafft zum tor einen ort weit weg vom
stadtlärm und vom lärm anderer menschen
wo man allein ist mit sich mit der natur
und dem universum damit man in sich
denen sich besser kennenlernen können
das ist der zweck des gebäudes ist
architekt zum tor ist dafür wohl der
beste architekt der welt auch wenn er
nicht religiös ist uns nicht in erster
linie sakrale bauten schafft erinnert
seine architektur an die lektionen der
religionen genau das bei handlichen
kapitel über architektur heutige
architekten müssen nicht unbedingt
kirchen bauen aber sie sollten sich an
dinge erinnern welche die kirchen
berücksichtigt haben nämlich räume zu
schaffen welche die seele berühren
wir benötigen nicht nur supermärkte
schwimmbäder und bahnhöfe obwohl diese
wichtig sind
wir brauchen auch gebäude welche die
seele der individuen berühren das tempel
projekt habe ich im buch beschrieben
aber wir haben es durch das zum tor
project ersetzt wir haben mit
verschiedenen ideen gespielt im buch
beschreibe ich eine anzahl von
gebäudetypen welche die säkulare welt
brauchen könnte dazu gehört auch ein
gebäude das wir tempel für die richtige
perspektive nennen
ein mächtiger raum in dem sich der
einzelne mensch winzig fühlt angesichts
der unendlichkeit des universums
ist diese gehen denn auch das ist eine
zentrale wirkungsvoller bauten
ich stelle mir vor dass wir eines tages
etwas ähnliches tun könnten aber
momentan konzentrieren wir uns auf das
säkulare kloster von zum tor
austria idee weil diese idee mit dem
tempel im londoner bankenviertel das hat
ja medial für einige aufregung gesorgt
und das habe viel widerspruch aber dann
ist dieses projekt jetzt erstmal
der fokus liegt auf dem zum tor project
das etwa in einem jahr fertig ist und
wunderbar werden soll
aber eigentlich gibt es doch immer mehr
leere kirchen es gibt immer mehr leere
klöster natürlich viele atheisten
bewundern die schönen bauten der
religionen aber sehen sie ich bin ein
kreativer mensch ich finde es schade
wenn wir aufhören würden gebäude für
spirituelle zwecke zu bauen nur weil wir
nicht mehr an die traditionellen
religionen glauben
simply because ich denke architekten
können sich an den sakralen bauten der
vergangenheit inspirieren und gebäude
schaffen die aus diesem erbe schöpfen
memory oder symptom rudel ein beispiel
ist die bruder klaus kapelle gibt zum
tor in deutschland errichtete das ist
keine traditionelle kapelle er eine art
säkularer tempel dieses wunderbare
gebäude zeigt wie architektur aussieht
wenn nicht religiöse architekten sich an
die lektionen der schönsten sakralbauten
erinnern die wir alle lieben was ich
mich frage wirklich die gleiche
atmosphäre die dann in so einem gebäude
herrscht weil macht nicht die spezielle
atmosphäre eine kathedrale oder auch
eine moschee oder was immer aus dass es
eben diesen gottesbezug gebiet oder also
dass es orte sind wo ich sage es mal ein
bisschen politische himmel und erde
berühren
wo man es gewohnt etwas ich denke das
ist möglich denn wir alle haben schon
solche momente erlebt zum beispiel
draußen in der natur nicht unbedingt in
einem sakralen gebäude dort kann uns ein
ähnliches gefühl erfassen nämlich das
bewusstsein wie klein wir sind
angesichts von etwas das schöner
intelligenter und geheimnisvoller ist
als der menschliche verstand je erfassen
kann
wieviel combo in front dann werden wir
demütig das können wir draußen erleben
oder auch in gebäuden die nicht
ausdrücklich religiös sind
ich verstehe was sie sagen wollen und
das betrifft alles was ich im buch
thematisieren
sie wollen mir sagen ich würde versuchen
religiöse dinge wie musikgemeinschaft
kunst oder architektur zu retten
diese würden aber nur ihre funktion
erfüllen wenn man glaubt diesen einwand
bringen auch gewisse gläubige schön und
gut sie reden von parks h moll messe
sie sagen wie wunderbar es ist sich eine
kathedrale anzuschauen und wie wohltuend
eine gemeinschaft sein kann
aber das wird nur wenn sie glauben der
glaube ist das getriebe dank den das
alles funktioniert worauf ich jeweils
antworten ich bin nicht sicher wie ich
glaube nicht aber ich liebe die
h-moll-messe ich glaube nicht aber ich
besucher gerne eine schöne kirche
ich glaube nicht aber ich mag religiöse
gemeinschaften schauen sie ich weiß
nicht wie viel kraft eine religion einen
geben kann denn ich habe das nie erlebt
ich weiß nur was ich fühle
und das ist auch sehr stark ich denke
viele atheisten sagen wir glauben nicht
aber diese dinge berühren und trotzdem
das möchte ich zur diskussion stellen
nämlich dass es funktioniert auch wenn
man das ganze gigantische glaubenssystem
nicht übernimmt
auch atheisten können diese wirkung
spüren ich weiß gewisse gläubige wänden
ein sieb iken die rosinen heraus sie
bedienen sich bei den religionen wie an
einem buffet
und ich antworte stimmt das tue ich aber
warum nicht
wir picken auch rosinen aus der
literatur wenn ich ihnen sage ich liebe
thomas mann aber auch am burghof und
tolstoi sagen sie auch nicht sie
beginnen sich am buffet der literatur
sie finden das normal man trifft eine
auswahl und schafft sein persönliches
pantheons das ist in ordnung wie und
auch wenn man nicht glaubt kann man mit
religiösen dingen dasselbe tun
ein thema was für sie wichtig ist dem
buch ist thema menschenbild wo sie sagen
auch hier kann man von religionen lernen
weil die religionen ein ganz anderes
menschenbild haben als die säkulare welt
nämlich religionen sehen den menschen
als schwach als sündig als lern
bedürftig als hilfsbedürftig kinder
gottes ist so ein ausdruck oder führt
ihren hirten brauchen die moderne welt
betrachtet erwachsene als eigenständig
rational und grundsätzlich in ordnung
wenn sie ein problem haben gehen sie zum
arzt
im übrigen kommen sie mit dem leben
zurecht ein europäischen system dass
unser bildungssystem sagt uns nicht wie
wir leben sollen
es bringt uns technische fähigkeiten bei
lehrt uns aber nicht weisheit und moral
es führt und tröstet uns nicht dass und
guy das 1000 künstlers in zentraler
stimmt dass ich meine die bücherregale
in buchläden sind doch voller
ratgeberliteratur so das ist eine art
von hilfe als das christentum im 19
jahrhundert anhänger verlor fragten sich
manche leute wie soll die gesellschaft
nun funktionieren wie sollen die
menschen geführt werden
wer sagt ihnen wie sie mit dem tod
umgehen und ein gutes leben führen
sollen
die erste antwort von nietzsche in
deutschland und john ruskin in england
lautet kultur und kunst sollen die
heiligen schriften ersetzen und die
humanwissenschaften sind unsere neue
religion in den dialogen von plato den
stücken von shakespeare und den märkten
von goethe können wir dinge finden die
uns führen
das ist eine schöne und sehr wahre idee
doch trotz der vielen bücher nehmen wir
sie nicht ernst wenn ich in zürich an
die universität ging er uns sagen würde
ich möchte humanwissenschaften studieren
weil ich mich verloren fühle weil ich
angst habe weil ich ein guter mensch
sein möchte und den sinn des lebens
nicht kenne
dann würden sie sagen mein gott würden
zum telefon greifen und der ambulanz
melden da ist ein verrückter im gebäude
anders gesagt unser tiefstes wesen und
unsere größten probleme sind in unserem
erziehungssystem nicht erwünscht auch
nicht in der kultur und in den
humanwissenschaften und das glauben wir
weil man irgendwie davon ausgeht dass
das leben leicht ist
man muss einzig erwachsenwerden sich von
den eltern abnabeln einen job finden die
einem gefällt eine liebesbeziehung
eingehen
vielleicht eine familie gründen zu sehen
wie die eltern sterben sich dem eigenen
tod stellen sich in den sarg legen das
ist alles es ist einfach jede
intelligente person schafft das wäre ein
wenig dumm ist und unterstützung braucht
kann ein selbsthilfebuch lesen aber
clevere leute schaffen das leben mit
links das ist die dominante elitäre
sicht welche die universitäre und
kulturelle maschinerie antreibt
ich finde das ist grundfalsch
wir wissen nicht wie wir legen sollen
wir haben nur eine zerbrechliche schale
in uns drin herrscht chaos
deshalb sind religionen so interessant
sie gehen davon aus dass wir kinder sind
wir sind verloren wir sind sünder
das ist ein nützlicher ausgangspunkt es
zeigt klar dass wir hilfe brauchen
ich befürworte nicht unbedingt die hilfe
und weisheit die uns religionen anbieten
aber ich bin einverstanden damit dass
wir von individuen nicht verlangen
können dass sie alle probleme alleine
lösen
aber auch eine kehrseite dieses
menschenbild wenn man den menschen
ständig vor augen hält wie sündigte sind
das dann vielleicht auch schuldgefühle
entwickeln oder dass das
selbstwertgefühl gestört wird was ja
wahrscheinlich in religiösen erziehung
auch geschehen ich hatte nie ein problem
mit dem konzept der erbsünde denn
eigentlich heißt dass wir alle haben
brüche im leben wir alle sind ein wenig
verrückt wie alle verhalten uns nicht
immer korrekt
wer sich verliebt schwärmt von der
angebeteten sie ist perfekt ein engel
eine wunderschöne kreatur und dann
zeigen sich die ersten
unvollkommenheiten sie hält das haus
nicht sauber ist ein wenig nachlässig
anders gesagt man meint man hätte einen
engel geheiratet und realisiert dass es
ein mensch ist
religionen sind da sehr weise sie sagen
uns wir sollen engel verehren und die
menschen tolerieren
sie anerkennen dass kein mensch perfekt
ist und das hat eine gute basis für den
beginn einer beziehung wenn man sagt ich
bin ein sünder es gibt brüche in meinem
leben ich bin in vieler hinsicht
verrückt und du wahrscheinlich auch aber
wir können eine beziehung beginnen und
hoffen dass es gut herauskommt mit uns
zwei sendern als späteren das ist viel
besser als die sagen wir kalifornische
art zu sagen ich bin schön und perfekt
du bist schön perfekt wir werden ein
glückliches leben haben und mein
jungunternehmen wird in ein paar monaten
florieren diese philosophie der
vollkommenheit die oft auf medizinische
und technologische perfektion beruht
halte ich für sehr gefährlich und eines
der hilfreichsten gegenmittel ist der
religiöse pessimismus den das judentum
der buddhismus und der katholizismus
kennen
der religiöse pessimismus anerkennt dass
es in diesem leben keine vollkommenheit
gibt wir alle haben brüche im leben das
leben ist voller leid wie das ist ein
wunderbarer ausgangspunkt ich sage am
morgen beim aufwachen das leben ist
voller leid wenn dann das tram
verspätung hat mein chef verärgert ist
und mein es nicht genügt kann ich sagen
das habe ich ja gewusst wer aber
aufsteht und denkt die menschen sind
perfekt es gibt nur ein paar kleine
probleme zu lösen und in wenigen jahren
wird dank dem apple computern und der
chemieindustrie alles perfekt sein
wer so denkt bekommt probleme deshalb
gefällt mir der religiöse pessimismus
eine andere sache die sie an religion
mögen sind die rituale der religionen
strukturieren die zeit die lebenszeit
jahreszeit mittels ritualen
was würden sie denn von ritualen am
liebsten übernehmen gibt es beispiele
village instruktor religionen
strukturieren die zeit
sie legen das ganze jahr über daten für
uns fest an denen wir uns mit wichtigen
ideen befassen sollen wir alle haben
unsere agenda
aber was er daran festhalten ist unser
persönliches leben unsere sitzungen
waren wir die kinder aus der schule
abholen müssen usw
es ist eine praktische religionen legen
einem psychologischen zeit live ist
darin heißt es am 30 märz treffen sie
den heiligen franziskus dann ist sein
geburtstag und sie lernen ein paar
seiner ideen gerne mit der zen buddhist
feiert mitte september eine zeremonie
die sehr schön feierliche mond
betrachtung genannt wird
tierisch als jude gedenkt man im
frühling am berg at lacourt der blumen
und der schönheit des neuen jahres als
atheist könnte ich sagen das brauche ich
nicht
ich kann irgendwann daran denken wie
schön das neue jahr ist dafür brauche
ich kein kalender kein fixes datum aber
religionen sind intelligent sie wissen
es gibt so vieles anders wir denken
wollen aber wir vergessen es weil wir
zerstreut sind wir wollen den
frühlingsbeginn nicht verpassen aber es
gibt so viele andere dinge religionen
legen deshalb daten für uns fest an
denen wir uns mit wichtigen ideen
befassen sollen und ich denke das ist
unerlässlich
wie gehen sie ihre familie zb mit
religiösen feiertagen
ich habe einen historischen zugang zu
diesen festen und erkläre meinen kindern
deren hintergrund und warum sie gefeiert
werden ich versuche ihnen auch klar zu
machen dass zb ostern ein christliches
fest ist aber auf einen heidnischen
brauch zurück geht nämlich den
zeremoniellen frühlingsbeginn und das
ist etwas faszinierendes sind das
christentum hat viel aus dem heidnischen
leben gestohlen und als heutiger atheist
und man könnte sagen als moderne heides
fühle ich mich frei sowohl vom
christentum als auch von den heiden
reichen zu stehlen die diesen festen
zugrunde liegen deshalb finde ich es so
wichtig dass sich die geschichte der
religionen kennen
dadurch wird das leben interessanter
dann denkt man nicht ich hasse wo es
dann da geht es nur um ostereier und ich
esse keine schokolade
man denkt vielmehr seit tausenden jahren
feiern die menschen den beginn des
jahres zyklus die neugeburt der erde
also er sah geschah das mit heidnischen
ritualen
dann kam das christentum und sah das ist
ein gutes symbol für die auferstehung
von jesus war und zu diesem frühlings
ritual passte und so wird das leben
interessanter
ich rate atheisten auch wenn ihr etwas
nicht mehr glaubt verliert nicht das
interesse daran das ist die botschaft
des buches
aber ich stelle mir vor an dieser stelle
sagen dann die religiösen wieder rituale
kann man nicht einfach so neue finden
die sind lange gewachsen sie haben eine
tradition das ist etwas anderes
ich würde das bestreiten wenn gläubige
finden nur die alten rituale sind gut
sage ich sie sind nicht mehr als rituale
plus zeit auch wir haben zeit und am
anfang sind neue rituale immer etwas
älter als die christen zum ersten mal
kommunion feiert und fanden die leute
das bestimmt seltsam so etwas braucht
zeit aber wir haben alle zeit der welt
und ohne es zu merken schaffen wir
ständig neue rituale zum beispiel
nationale feiertage ein neueres ritual
ist der muttertag die haben einen tag
für mütter bestimmt und den valentinstag
viele rituale sind nicht sonderlich
intelligent am muttertag zb darf man
seiner mutter nur danken
die meisten menschen lieben ihre mutter
haben aber auch schon hass empfunden
zumindest ist ihre beziehung nicht nur
unproblematisch hätte ich den muttertag
gefunden hätte ich ein ritual geschaffen
indem man der mutter danken sich aber
auch bei ihr beschweren darf damit man
sich gegenseitig vergeben kann entity
vergriffen
genau das bieten viele christliche feste
an
es geht darum zu vergeben und vergebung
zu bekommen wir müssen unsere modernen
rituale also verbessern
ich würde am muttertag gerne sagen
können mutter du warst nicht mehr zu mir
als ich fünf war oder so dann könnte man
auch mehr lieben was mir an vielen
religiösen ritualen gefällt ist dass sie
psychologisch intelligenz sind
dann müsste man das wahrscheinlich für
die väter analog auch machen genau das
bildungsthema ist für sie haben es schon
ein paar mal angesprochen sehr wichtig
und sie sagen die säkulare bildung eben
die lehrt nicht wie man leben soll
aber es dafür nicht gerade auch die
philosophie zuständig sie sind ja
philosoph also die philosophie
beschäftigt sich doch es ja ihr
kerngeschäft moral oder sinn des lebens
solche fragen sie haben recht und zwar
so sehr dass ich weinen könnte
denn genau das sollte die philosophie
tun
sie sollte uns moral werden und so
weiter aber wo steht sie heute
es gibt philosophie professorin an den
universitäten von denen wir selten etwas
zu nehmen
sie schreiben für andere professoren und
leben in einer eigenen abgeschotteten
welt
die philosophie geht auf sogar der sem
antiken griechenland zurück der auf der
straße und auf märkten lehrte heute
spreche er im fernsehen
heutzutage nimmt die philosophie einen
verschwindend kleinen platz 1
sie ist nicht mehr als ein witz in
diesen tagen in zürich fragte mich ein
taxifahrer nach meinem beruf als ich
sagte ich sei philosoph rivero davon
verstehe ich nichts die frage was
verstehen sie nicht
ich habe ihn ja nur gesagt was ich
beruflich tue doch seine panische
reaktion zeigt dass philosophie ein
schreckliches wort ist fernsehsendungen
für ihre unternehmen etwas dagegen aber
ich denke philosophie sollte die
religion ersetzen
sie sollte deren aufgabe übernehmen und
nicht nur die philosophie auch viele
kunstwerke sollten das tun
unbedingt aber das ist nicht der fall
philosophie wird in einem akademischen
sehr nüchternen umfeld gelehrt dort weiß
man nicht dass wir um drei uhr morgens
meinen dass wir uns verloren fühlen und
panische angst haben an universitäten
gibt es wenig verständnis für unsere
vordringlichsten bedürfnisse in diesen
disziplinen wird unsere verletzlichkeit
nicht respektiert man gesteht uns nicht
die kindlichkeit zu welche die
religionen immer berücksichtigt haben
und sie machen jetzt ernst mit dieser
neuen art von von bildung von
philosophie sie haben die school of life
gegründet in london die schule des
lebens
was ist die schule des lebens vielleicht
nur kurz zu sehen
die lebensschule ist eine institution
die versucht weisheit zu leeren
das ist eine seltsame idee das tut sonst
wir lehren weisheit in verschiedenen
bereichen im arbeitsumfeld im
familienleben in der kindererziehung im
umgang mit verschiedenen ängsten in der
freizeitgestaltung mitten in london
geben wir jeden abend seminaren
wir haben einen schulungsraum und ein
unterrichts zimmer und jeden monat gibt
es einen grossanlass wir tun ganz
einfach das was die universitäten tun
sollten aber nicht tun
wir schaffen einen ort der uns hilft zu
leben einen ort für die seele
ich gründete die schule als ich dieses
buch schrieb das war ein paralleler
prozess
die schule ist nicht die antwort auf die
probleme die ich im buch beschreibe ich
lancierte das projekt weil wir eine neue
vision für erziehung und bildung
brauchen
es genügt nicht den menschen technisches
know how zu vermitteln um sie auf die
wirklichen herausforderungen des lebens
vorzubereiten
in reichen ländern wie der schweiz oder
großbritannien können wir über die rein
technische bildung hinausgehen
wir müssen den menschen helfen sich
selbst besser zu verstehen und zu
akzeptieren damit sie mehr oder weniger
gesund bleiben können
man staunt ja dass es in dieser school
of life auch sonntagspredigt gibt es
sonder service
man kann sie sich auch im internet
ansehen und damit wir einen eindruck
davon bekommen schauen wir kurz rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen dank an die sängerinnen wir können
jetzt überall hingehen und alles
anpacken das ist die kraft der musik sie
motiviert und verändert uns und macht
uns offen für veränderungen
was haben wir da gemacht
wir wollten in der schule jeden monat
einen grossanlass organisieren und alle
dazu einladen an einem sonntag und
natürlich waren wir inspiriert davon
dass gottesdienste in kirchen zu
erreichen versuchen im mittelpunkt von
gottesdiensten steht die predigt sie
soll uns helfen unser leben verändern
und uns vielleicht sogar retten
ein herr peter naef ein baby safe in der
säkularen welt haben wir das nicht
vorlesungen sind nüchterne wissen zur
meldungen und die studenten hören ruhig
und emotionslos zu ist meine feier ist
leidenschaftlicher und deshalb hatten
wir die idee säkulare zeremonien
abzuhalten
jeden monat spricht jemand zum publikum
in der einspielung haben sie nicht
gesehen das kann ein philosoph sein ein
künstler eine politikerin ein firmenchef
eine modedesignerin der inhaber einer
computerfirma company verschiedene leute
treten auf und geben uns eine wichtige
lektion fürs leben etwas das sie gelernt
haben und dass sie mit anderen teilen
wollen
vielleicht wollen sie etwas schlimmem
warnen oder etwas gutes aufzeigen
wir haben einen enormen erfolg mit 800
bis 1000 menschen kommen jeweils in
einem saal zusammen
wir singen auch miteinander religiöse
lieder und popsongs und andere moderne
songs welche die redner auswählen können
in der zeremonie die sie gezeigt haben
sprach ich über pessimismus dann seinen
chor aus den songs von elton john weil
sie dazu passen
wie auch immer wir haben jeweils viel
spaß aber ein ernsthaftes ziel denn
viele bedürfnisse deretwegen die
menschen früher sonntags zur kirche
gehen haben wir auch heute noch auch
wenn man nicht gläubig ist braucht man
etwas
lasst uns doch kreativ sein lasst uns
neue dinge erfinden wir sind nicht am
ende der geschichte angelangt
was sie dann wahrscheinlich nicht
übernehmen ist die doktrin also in jeder
religion gibt es eine doktrin gibt es um
staatliche wahrheiten und wahrscheinlich
ist das ja auch einer der gründe warum
religion erfolgreich sind das macht das
leben einfach einfacher wenn man nicht
alles immer hinterfragen muss
aber das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt detail
denn sie nicht völlig richtig ich
übernehme keine doktrin
ich denke wir leben in einer welt in der
niemand mehr je sagen kann das ist die
wahrheit auf diesen 500 seiten findet
ihr alles wir sind neugierig reisen
ständig durch die welt und hören was
verschiedene menschen zu sagen hat
wir leben in einer art wiki welt in der
die wahrheit aus verschiedenen quellen
kommt wir schließen die wahrheit nicht
ein und beraubten da drin ist
sie haben also recht ich sage nicht dass
hier ist weisheit und alles andere
stimmt nicht
ich interessiere mich für die weisheit
und für die kunst zu leben
aber diese lebensweisheit kann aus
vielen quellen kommen
sie sagten die religionen seien wegen
ihrer doktrin erfolgreich gewesen
ich würde hinzufügen sie scheiterten
auch daran
für mich ist religion nie anziehender
als wenn ihre vertreter sagen wir wissen
nichts
diese erkenntnis findet man in der
katholischen müsste einige katholische
mystiker sagen wir wissen nichts unser
geist ist leer nur gott weiß dazu
bekennt sich auf der buddhismus und die
jüdische philosophie volks ebene geben
sich religionen oft sehr dogmatisch aber
in intellektuellen kreisen würden wohl
viele dem berühmten jüdischen sprichwort
zustimmen der mensch denkt und gott
lacht was in etwa heißt wir denken viel
aber einzig gott weiß diese religiöse
nicht dogmatische art zu denken
entspricht mir und den meisten atheisten
sie haben es schon erwähnt die meisten
beispiele aus ihrem buch stammen ja
entweder aus dem jüdisch christlichen
aus der jüdisch-christlichen tradition
oder aus dem buddhismus warum eigentlich
kommt der islam nicht vor
die limited space ich musste mich
beschränken ich wollte nicht alle
religionen miteinander vergleichen und
musste mich entscheiden
also werde ich die jüdisch-christliche
und die östliche tradition auf den islam
verzichtete ich auch weil ich den
eindruck hatte er enthalte wenig was ein
atheist befürworten oder mögen könnte es
gibt ein paar dinge aber die meisten
sind auch im christentum enthalten es
war also eine pragmatische wahl
außerdem denke ich dieses buch ist für
unsere welt bestimmt für länder wie die
schweiz die usa großbritannien in denen
die religion nicht dominant ist
ich würde kein solches buch über den
islam für jemanden in saudi arabien
schreiben dieses buch entstand auf dem
hintergrund religiöser toleranz und für
säkularisierte länder mit verbreitetem
atheismus gibt gewisse dinge die man
adoptieren absolutely ganz klar lücke in
jeder religion gibt es solche aspekte in
der religion der azteken im hinduismus
und so weiter denn in jeder religion
findet man menschliche intelligenz die
versucht mit dem gleichen ängsten
umzugehen
mit angst vor dem tod mit problemen in
der gemeinschaft es sind die gleichen
probleme die uns dazu gebracht haben
religionen zu erfinden und man findet
überall faszinierende antworten wir
haben nicht mehr allzu viel zeit ich
möchte die restliche zeit noch an nützen
zu fragen wie die reaktionen waren auf
ihr buch und auf ihr projekt ich meine
sie haben so ein bisschen gesagt
religiöse haben sich zum teil auch also
die fans nicht so toll dass der eine
kommt und einfach so die rosinen raus
das ist mein erfolgreichstes buch seit
jahren 1,5 millionen exemplare der
englischen originalausgabe wurden bisher
verkauft
der mich warum kam als das buch heraus
kam dachte ich meine güte sie werden die
zerreißen die gläubigen und die
atheisten
erstaunlicherweise waren die reaktionen
der gläubigen sehr wohl
der erzbischof von canterbury die
höchste autorität der englischen kirche
sprach darüber in der ostermesse
er sagte dass er ein buch dass jeder
christ lesen können großartig feindliche
reaktionen bekam ich von gewissen
aggressiven amerikanischen atheisten aus
dem umfeld von richard dawkins
geschrieben hier und starteten eine
kampagne mit der behauptung ich sei
religiös wenn sie bei google bot und
religiös eingeben
tauchen viele websites auf in denen
steht ich sei religiös man habe mich in
kirchen gesehen und ich sage im geheimen
katholik total verrückte behauptung ja
verschwörungstheorien vor allem weil sie
nicht akzeptieren können das nicht als
atheist etwas positives über religionen
sage und gewisse wenn auch nicht alle
aspekte motto summer special agent ein
bis das zeigt wie gespalten die welt
inzwischen geworden ist und wie
notwendig dieses buch ist denn es
braucht gemäßigte ungläubige die sagen
wir können von der religion lernen sie
zu verstehen versuchen und dinge daraus
verwenden
im grunde genommen
ich habe die atheisten tatsächlich in
zweit- und eine trennung zwischen den
gemäßigten atheisten und den hardlinern
bewirkt die hardliner finden nicht nur
religion sei falsch sondern sie sei
gefährlich dumm und kindisch vor allem
aber sei sie eine gefährliche illusion
so denken die hardcore atheisten und sie
gewinnen an einfluss sehr dogmatisch so
dogmatisch wie die religion und dann
gibt es die gemäßigteren atheisten wie
zum beispiel sagen ich glaube nicht an
gott aber mir gefällt die
weihnachtsmesse ich lese gern texte des
heiligen augustinus oder findet die
schriften von blaise pascal interessant
es sind menschen die sich den gedanken
gewisser genies nicht verschließen
genies die aus den religionen hervor
gegangen sind und deren lehrern einfluss
behalten ob man sie glaubt oder nicht
damit rutschen sofort im grunde sind
religionen viel zu interessant zu
komplex und schön als dass man sie
einfach mit ihnen überlassen sollte die
daran glauben sie sind für uns alle und
nicht zuletzt auch für ungläubige
tarifes gesagt es extrem erfolgreiches
buch es hat aber schon auch harsche
kritik gegeben also zum beispiel ihr
landsmann terry eagleton bekannter
literatur theoretiker der hat im
guardian aber gar nicht nette lehrbuch
geschrieben
er fand das banal und drei saudis profis
ist eine extreme kasse lag der verfasser
dieses artikels ist ein tiefgläubiger
katholik er fand ich würde seine
religion beleidigen
damit war er eine ausnahme die meisten
katholiken haben nicht so richtig es gab
aber tatsächlich einige religiöse
kritiker die sich wie dieser mann
angegriffen fühlten
dieses buch auf der titelseite steht es
sei gefährlich denn ich sage etwas das
ein wenig gefährlich ist religion ist
falsch religion ist nicht wahr
religion ist eine illusion
aber diese illusion ist voller weisheit
und voller dinge die wir nützen und
stehen sollten wir sollten nicht zur
religion zurückkehren wir sollten
vorwärts gehen und uns von der religion
weg bewegen nachdem wir von ihr gelernt
haben
sie sehen also dass diese botschaft ganz
unterschiedliche leute beleidigen kann
obwohl ich das keineswegs tun wollte das
ist mein 15 das buch die jedes buch das
man herausgibt hat befürworter und
kritiker
das ist unwichtig ausschlaggebend ist ob
darin dinge gesagt werden die gewisse
leute wichtig finden und das habe ich
glaube ich erreicht es gab auch die
kritik dass sei alles gar nicht neu was
sie sagen aber das behaupten sie
eigentlich
es gab leute die das vor mir schon
thematisiert haben
ich erwähne im buch zb der neunzehnten
jahrhundert lebte und ein
religion der humanität gründete wie er
sie nannte er nahm eine version des
katholizismus und entfernte daraus allen
aberglauben die jungfrau maria ersetzte
er mit seiner freundin mathilde die man
am beten sollte anstelle der heiligen
sollte man berühmte wissenschaftler und
philosophen wie descartes verehren
eine verrückte idee in brasilien hatte
er viele anhänger
dort gibt es immer noch gering er hatte
verrückte ideen aber ich spreche
ausführlich über ihn denn er hatte
interessante ansichten den namen august
konto kennt kaum jemand mehr und niemand
liest heute seine schriften
ich habe ihn aus der vergessenheit
hervorgeholt denn er wird viele wichtige
fragen auf sie haben recht wir stellen
uns seit etwa 150 jahren solche fragen
es begann mit nicole ludwig feuerbach
und dauert bis heute an und ich finde
wir müssen diesen bereich weiter
erforschen
mein buch ist ein bescheidener beitrag
zu einer langen debatte darüber wie wir
in einer säkularen welt gut ohne
religion leben können ohne die religion
zu vergessen
angst davor dass sie jetzt zum gelacht
werden einen neuen bewegung denn die
gore verehrung in der religion die idee
dass ein mensch die wahrheit für sich
gepachtet hat ist ein problem für mich
die besten momente der religionen sind
wie gesagt jene in denen religiöse
führungspersönlichkeiten sagen ich weiß
nichts wenn mutter sagt ich bin ignorant
wenn die meisten menschen sich
eingestehen dass sie nichts wissen
das finde ich gut mit anderen worten
gurus empfinde ich als fundamental und
intelligent denn sie unterbinden die
verantwortung des einzelnen für sich
selbst zu denken
eigentlich wollen die religionen das
auch nicht verhindern
sie wollen uns nicht zu automaten und
der sklaven machen trotzdem werden auf
diese weise immer wieder menschen
manipuliert doch ich denke jeder muss
die verantwortung für sich selbst
übernehmen
ich meine man kann das ja vielleicht
auch gar nicht kontrollieren also sie
haben so wie ich weiß schon 38.000
facebook fans
vielleicht werden sie dann einfach
ungewollt zum kuchen gemacht
glücklich wenn ich lese und anhänger
habe ist das toll aber meine leser sind
unabhängige denker denn meine bücher
befassen sich mit dem unabhängigen
denkens das ist so wunderbaren der
modernen welt wir können unabhängig
denken
die gefahr besteht einzig das wäre so
sehr allein gelassen werden dass wir
nicht wissen wie das geht
deshalb brauchen wir ein bildungssystem
das uns man denken hilft ein aspekt denn
sie außen vor lassen wo ich habe finde
das ist ein ganz zentraler aspekt von
religion ist er als der ganze soziale
bereich dass religion ganz viel
armenfürsorge hilfsprojekte hier alles
mögliche machen in diesem bereich warum
kommt das bei ihnen
ich würd mal ein ganzes kapitel der
gemeinschaft und das können die
religionen am besten
sie bringen menschen miteinander in
verbindung sie machten den fremden den
anderen der fremd aussieht zu deinem
freund
denken sie an eine gewöhnliche messe in
einer katholischen kirche
sobald die türen geschlossen sind ist in
diesem raum jeder ein potenzieller
volkmann reicht der person zur linken
und zur rechten die hand zum
friedensgruß und kann sein herz
gegenüber einem fremden öffnen
wo sonst in der heutigen welt ist das
möglich an einem fussballmatch in einem
restaurant nein im schwimmbad nicht
wirklich religionen werden systematisch
gemeinschaften und sie können das sehr
gut sie sorgen dafür dass wir uns
begegnen können
meistens lernen wir menschen heutzutage
durch die medien kennen
darin werden schreckliche dinge über sie
berichtet dass sie mörder pädophile und
verrückte sind kein wunder dass wir
einander auf der straße nicht anschauen
und mit niemandem reden denn wir denken
alle seien verrückt
sobald man sich in einer gemeinschaft
wie einer religiösen gemeinde sicher
fühlt schwindet das misstrauen und man
öffnet sein herz das kann man auch ohne
religion tun
dafür muss man nicht ans übernatürliche
glauben die religionen verstehen sich
einfach besser darauf gewisse leute
wenden ein und was ist mit facebook
das ist doch ein gutes medium menschen
zusammen
aber die sozialen medien verbinden leute
über gemeinsame interessen über die
liebe zum fischen oder zum skifahren
die religionen fördern und stärken sie
nehmen menschen die nichts miteinander
gemein haben nicht gleich alt sind nicht
die gleiche hautfarbe und einen anderen
beruf oder lohn haben und sagen ihr alle
seid kinder gottes
das ist eine schwierige botschaft man
schaut die person neben sich an und
sagte sie hat eine andere hautfarbe
sieht anders aus das macht mir ein wenig
angst aber wir begegnen einem menschen
ist und das ist die zentrale botschaft
der religion sehr spannende stunde ich
danke ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie mein
gast
danke für die einladung
[Musik]
dieses gespräch mit aller darüber ob
dort finden sie natürlich auf unserer
website aber auch als dvd ist es zu
haben zu bestellen wie immer bei
schweizer radio und fernsehen redaktion
sternstunden 80 52 zürich ihre e mail
schreiben sie an stern kombinat srf
punkt ch die heilsarmee hat sich ins
fernsehen gesungen in diesen tagen
nächsten sonntag fragen wir nach wofür
die soldaten gottes mit der sozialen
ader eigentlich genau stehen und wir
zeigen ihnen ein film über evangelikale
in der schweiz warum sind die
freikirchen so erfolgreich hier dies in
einer woche in der sternstunde regierung
noch aber ist pfingsten und wir nehmen
sie jetzt mit in die ostschweiz aus der
kirche sankt mauritius in appen zellen
übertragen mit den römisch-katholischen
pfingstgottesdienst anschließend begeben
wir uns auf die suche nach der idealen
reisegeschwindigkeit in der sternstunde
kunst zeigen wir sehen dass koffer von
peter liechti
denn kult filme über den künstler roman
signer
[Musik]
pfingsten das ist einer der großen
wichtigen festtage im kirchenjahr
sichtbar wird das unter anderem im
appenzell jedes jahr immer an pfingsten
wandern auch dort nicht wenige frauen in
festtagstracht zur kirche aber nur bei
schönem wetter messe schadet den
wunderschönen teuren stoffen und ins
auto einsteigen gegen den hohen haben
schon gar nicht das motto des heutigen
gottesdienstes in der mauritiuskirche
heißt werdet anfänger pfarrer stefan
guggenbühl fragt ob die kirchen nicht
noch mal neu anfangen müssten noch
einmal sorgfältig nachlesen wie das war
als alle mit dem heiligen geist erfüllt
wurden und in fremden sprachen zu reden
begann damit wären wir eben bei
pfingsten und den fest täglichen frauen
in ihrem pracht